people are hilarious i was uh recently
in uh
had actually the wildest day ever in my
life that was so many things happened in
a row so i went to a wedding in l.a
andrew uh andrew schultz
and
with whitney cummings and and and joe
rogan and a bunch of other fascinating
people it's just
speaking of weirdos does the comedian
like the reason i find the comedians
awesome one they're authentic they're
just cool people yeah yeah but they're
also just weird like you don't become a
comedian for not being like [ __ ] up in
all kinds of different interesting ways
anyway so there's the wedding
i'm
um you know me it was only carbs at the
wedding so i didn't eat i didn't eat for
a long time before so i was like already
fasted
20 hours 25 hours
and but so that this whole story of
everything that happens is is lex like
40 hours fasted
with joe rogan drinking a lot of whiskey
and so you're drinking too oh heavy on
40 oh my god that's crazy so it is
calories that was my only source of
calories is the whiskey and i
so i didn't trust myself with carbs when
i'm drunk i just don't enjoy it because
i'll forget and i just enjoy eating like
a strict healthy diet when i'm drunk
because
i'd rather eat more food that's healthy
yeah yeah versus not and so anyway so
then we went to to vegas
together
and then uh
just kept doing wild thing after another
wild thing uh
rogan opened up for whitney cummings he
just like showed up at a random party
that he wasn't invited and he did a
thing he almost started a fight because
some guys said stop spread yelled at him
said stop spreading misinformation
uh
and then
we run into david goggins at vault this
is my first time meeting david i i've
talked to david a lot
over the phone and we were supposed to
do a thing together and this is me trash
out of my mind
meeting david for the first time with
his incredible wife oh rogan's wife was
there by the way
joe rogan's wife david's wife
made me realize that i really want to be
married
because
they're not
they make
um
their partners better yeah
like that i was
um there's a certain aspect of marriage
that i'm afraid of that like your
partner takes you away from life you
don't get to experience life as much
but this was like they were enriching
them i don't know it's like
the world's most powerful support group
it was cool anyway so then of course
drunk lex is uh
challenges goggins to push-ups i saw
this on instagram whatever we're in the
middle of this and you're in your suit
in this suit in the middle of casino
there's a crowd gathering
like it's joe rogan
me and david goggins and i'm just doing
push-ups with him and rogan is like
commentating and yelling and screaming
it was is surreal and just going on to
the next thing and next thing the next
thing like this and then drove
um
all the way from vegas back to uh to la
with with joe and whitney and his wife
and
it was like what what is this and all of
it is done in 24 hours
the one valuable lesson is don't fast
and drink
like excessively
so i've learned that because what
happens is um
liquor hits your mind my mind sorry i'll
speak about my particular mind
like the intellectual part of my brain
got hit really hard really fast so i was
not able to even more so than usual
stitched together sentences i understood
every well
so like made you an immigrant again
so like meeting david i want to say so
many things he's so inspiring to me
right but all i said was like hello
and i and i like i remember like opening
my mouth to like try to say more and i
was like
and then i would just close my mouth and
not be able to say anymore
this is why this is one of the reasons i
don't drink ever yeah
it removes certain
barriers like it allows you to maybe
have fun that you wouldn't otherwise but
yeah definitely for a person who values
intellectual
eloquence but i also hate being hungover
the hungover party yeah that's the worst
yeah and you also like i did this to
myself
yeah
but it also teaches me that this too
shall pass
because i've been hungover and i've quit
drinking so many times in my life
that it realizes it makes you realize
that all the unpleasant feelings
all you have to do is just wait it out
okay fine it took me a long time to
realize that that expression means the
other thing
what's the other thing if things are
going great this too shall pass
yeah i always talk about suffering no i
always thought about it as being more
like don't worry if things are bad it'll
pass it's like it's also like if
something's going great it's not gonna
be this way forever
it's like bukowski said love is a fog
that fades with the first daylight of
reality
you